hey everyone it's Mike from motorflows
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you could join me for today's video I'll
be discussing the uh order flow that
took place today you know after actually
before the market closed some people
some pretty pretty prominent people
um that follow on Twitter were
commenting on how bearish the orderful
look like not just for today but sort of
overall in market conditions it's sort
of uh crashy in a way and I'm not trying
to predict that there's going to be a
market crash or anything like that but
their comment was that you know it
really felt uh very shaky in the sense
of uh there's just no buyers out there
and you know I talk about a few of the
interesting things that I I thought was
interesting in the order flow today and
again you know I'm not trying to
cherry-pick thing I'm just going through
you know the interesting order flow you
know sometimes I put these videos up
there it kills me people say whoa you go
to show you know your training accounts
and all that stuff I'm just trying to
show you what was interesting in the
order flow right it's whether you want
to take it and use it in your article
that's the whole point of my channel
right is to educate people and teach
them what to look for in the order flow
just be honest if you're new to order
flow it's confusing it's daunting
because there's a lot of numbers here
and you know some numbers matter more
than others okay because I think people
have uh you know are averse to looking
at numbers you know math phobia or
whatever my kids have that for sure but
um yeah let's take a look at the orfo so
you know just really quick on on a bar
chart right we were just coming into the
cash open and we just started making new
lows bounced up and then we had you know
basically all day down we did get a
couple bounces like here around 11
o'clock we rallied from this low at uh
seven all the way up to 20 you know 24.
um sold back down getting small you know
that was pretty much the big bounce
right after the one after the open but
you know we had a nice little bounce
here but not much again you're talking
one and a quarter up to nine and a half
so just about uh is that about eight and
a quarter points and then we just kept
selling off selling off and got through
some you know psychological levels 4 400
uh you know 44.50 is not even on this
chart here this is 44.50 right here
okay so you know always keep an eye out
on those psychological levels I want to
discuss those and you know it was
interesting because yesterday we had a
big rally if you remember
right all day we were just pretty much
uh you know after the cash open about 30
minutes started making new highs and it
was Off to the Races going up and then
even after the close after the cash
close right here we got that uh big move
up back up into the 70s
um
you know before the Futures closed and
then reopened for the next session so
let's take a look at today's overflow
and sort of dissect it if you will so
let's take a look here
okay so again Cash open
um
we open our well not open on our lows
but we open right near our lows and
touch the low next bar next you know the
next one two three four five six next
six minutes just keep making new lows
okay so that was that was bearish and
his own right obviously
but that's not going to predict you know
a 70 point sell-off in the S PS now we
did hit this low down here at uh 451
then we got a nice rally honestly we got
this nice rally all the way up to uh 68
and three quarters you know I just
thought it was interesting on how the
market stopped up here around 68 and a
quarter I do have these two areas on
here which were some Prominent Point of
controls being referenced from earlier
um you know prior to the cash opening
but on this move up right it was yeah it
was a decent move right I mean you're
seeing you know we got this nice value
area that's untested and you know we
come down sort of test the logo within a
tick at the low and then we got nice
aggressive buying coming in here one two
three four five buying imbalances you
know Gap in the value between these two
bars
um going up again is picking up ahead of
steam
but one thing that I found shaky is the
delta in here okay because
I always like to watch Deltas on moves
you know because one of the signs of a
move that's sort of weakening all right
if this is a move up and it is because
we're coming up from our lows here at
the 51 area we're trading you know
almost 15 points higher up here and yeah
you got nice buying here 960 in the
Delta 673
232 so it's still positive
but it's sort of going in the opposite
direction that you would like to see
right you'd rather see it be like
232 here and this bar is close to 960
960. okay you want to see the Delta keep
expanding if you know positive I mean
it's still a positive
but it's just not as strong then you get
up here and you got you know negative
Delta positive Delta negative Delta
minus 592 plus 627 this is sort of your
blow off up here then minus 663. so you
know these two sort of cancel each other
out in a way minus 592 plus 627 then you
got uh 663 negative
Max Delta is just one so it's quite
small
and then again more negative Delta minus
574 then you get a small Delta minus
seven again I'm not reading much into
the minus seven that's a small number I
mean you know this is a one minute chart
so if there was you know an extra
nanosecond it could have been positive
five or something so again I'm not
putting too much weight in the negative
Delta just because it's minus seven and
you get a bar with positive Delta 677
and this is one of those things that's
got your shoulders shaking your head
like okay is this Market going to start
is this the is this a pullback right
from this high is this a pullback well I
know I've got resistance up here at 80
actually 69 and a quarter okay so if I'm
going to Rally
all right I know I'm going to run into
some resistance up here
oh we don't right we don't build off
that Delta we got X bar positive 16
Delta doesn't even go any higher it ends
up being a red candle right then you get
this nice Gap in the value between this
Bar's value area low and this Bar's
value area high even got a stack selling
a balance in there and you've got
um six sound imbalances coming in here
okay so it's quite strong negative
then again another strong negative Delta
792 379 400 another Gap in value here
okay then you make the new low negative
Delta 1286 that's what you're expecting
to see right you're going into lows you
want to see negative Delta you want to
see a strong negative Delta the minus
1286 was
um you know pretty strong you know in
the last 15 20 minutes okay I mean you
know when I look at Deltas I compare it
is 1286 strong you know I'm comparing it
to what's happening in recent history I
don't I'm not going to parse it and say
well at 8 43 you know I traded 1710 so
it's not that strong you know it's
strong because I'm just comparing it to
sort of the the last 10 or 15 minutes
okay then you get you know a couple bars
small green
you know one green bar and uh
what do we got here a positive Delta on
this red candle but what's interesting
is 4450 right a psychological level
okay
there's not much volume going through
here I mean there's 856 355 at nine and
a three quarters so it got through there
you know I I was
kind of expecting to see over a thousand
on the bid okay but you need then you
know it traded back up
um you know the bar closed up here at 20
51 and a quarter and then you know some
more bidden came in there at 44.50 you
see the 641
um traded there got down through there
okay you know there's some bids coming
in here at 44.50
you know and the next bar is green so
you know I'm watching to see if it comes
back down to 44.50 what's going to
happen right because honest this volume
that's coming in here the a56 348 641
523 you know that's you know again one
of your stronger volumes coming in down
here at the low you know again
psychological level
we come down through it
and somebody just sweeps right through
the 50s right they take out the 139 that
was there 40 and 64. right you don't
have a selling a balance of the 139
because it's 139 against 17 but you got
40 against zero 64 against one how do I
know that's a sweep is because there's
no counter trade
okay so it's coming through what I feel
is a psychological level of 4450 and it
sweeps through there to me that's a good
sign right if anything I'd sort of be
excited I'm more happy that it's come
down and broke through it on a some sign
of aggressive selling
obviously a strong negative Delta minus
1410 and we just keep making new lows
okay
Divergence have fails Divergence that
fails
right then you get down here to one and
a quarter okay and then this was
interesting because you know I'm always
looking for when you're making new lows
where's the size coming in
the market
notice it's not coming in at 41. it's
coming in basically around one and a
quarter one and a half
okay that's interesting
you see 8 13 415 670
sorry uh 349 8 30 yeah all right one and
a half
one and a quarter eight thirteen four
fifteen
five thirty one 670
1081 so 1500 another thousand two and a
half thousand
um
two and a half thousand three and a half
thousand so close to four thousand
contracts
going through at one and a quarter
okay that's decent
is it going to hold or not it doesn't it
breaks right through you got the exposed
value area right here where it doesn't
get tested in the next bar so yes you're
seeing a lot of selling right because if
remember if there's technical levels
psychological levels but the market is
flow driven it's just going to blow
right through those levels right it's
not going to respect levels as it would
if it was just a normal trading day
right I'll say normal distribution but
just sort of you know normal trading
conditions there's something bigger
taking place and this is coming in you
know even in here this is already
trading at 41 right again there's still
more of the move to be had but what I
want to talk about next
right so again you know if I see strong
areas where I think there should be
strong support coming in and the
Market's just sort of getting right
through that with impunity
then I'm starting to think that hey you
know what we could be
looking at a trend day a flow driven
Market
but I want to talk about this bounce
right you get a nice bearish primary
point of control sticking out there
um the bounce that took place around 11.
right because there was a decent bounce
again you know it's anytime you're
making lows
you always
want to be looking for a reason to buy
potentially
right but again on a flow driven day you
might not get a reason right because to
be honest whenever you're making these
lows there's not a lot really of bullish
order flow going through
right so there's nothing really to talk
about these lows I mean yeah you have a
Divergence you know I remember years ago
one of my customers is having lunch with
him or dinner rather and he was telling
me that you know some guy had the secret
system on reading order flow
they wanted to sell them for you know
how many thousands of dollars and all it
was was just this it was a Divergence it
was a new low with positive Delta
and he knows my customer knows and I
know that
that's not a system right all that is is
just basically you have
buying coming in at a low right and why
would you have buying coming in at low
well it could be a number of reasons it
could be profit taking right everyone
that was short from above all sudden got
it you know they want to take some money
off the table there's going to be some
aggressive buying coming in but um let's
take a look at this this bounce off this
low because this was a
halfway decent bounce right it went from
six or sorry 07
you know got as high as uh I think 20
almost 24 at this 24 and a quarter right
here before It reversed and started
selling off again
but on this move up
right we hit the low guy still got
negative Delta and it's positive
positive positive negative positive
positive positive right and we're seeing
you know stack buying and balance coming
in here although it's kind of weak right
it's 39 34 115.
um you got the value area that's not
tested until you know a few minutes
later and then it's still rallying so
you know these two bars you got some
nice bullish information
you know we didn't quite get down we got
as low as that was 07 right and in my
head I'm thinking 44 double O is a
psychological level
right the big the big uh as we say on on
the trading floor figure
um and so they start rallying back up
get all the way up to
get into the 20s 18 to 20s start going
sideways then when we get up here okay
around this 24 ish area right I've got
the bearish slingshot point of control
I've got that's this right here this red
point of control I've got this
um bearish Regular point of control I've
got one two three four selling
imbalances and then it comes right back
up right bullish probably important
control Gap in value thinking oh okay
maybe this is just a little bit of a
pullback
because this is a nice size Gap here in
the value between this bar and this bar
right value area high is 20 value area
low here is one and a half
then the next bar goes inside
that's not what you like to see anytime
you have sort of a big bar like an
expansion bar if you will then the next
bar is kind of a doji and it goes inside
this is a doji I know because it's gray
it's telling me that you know open and
close at the same price and it's inside
of the previous bar right an inside bar
but more importantly this one's inside
of the previous bars value area right
which is not a good sign so I'm it's got
positive Delta 760. right so I mean this
looks like hey you know what maybe it's
all systems go but I know that I got
this slingshot point of control here at
23 and a half I've got this bearish
Mount imported controller 23.
okay these are sort of my resistance
areas
I want to watch how the market reacts to
it does get through but then it just
goes sideways and then it kicks off a
nice bearish value area here right how
do I know it's bearish well it's because
it's
not tested in the next bar that's why
the zone is being drawn out come back up
get within one tick a single print here
okay but more importantly what do I see
I see a red candle
the buying imbalance okay and here I got
a doji candle with two buying imbalances
got another red candle here
with two bind imbalances I got one two
three four five six seven eight sound
imbalances in this red candle
and I got two bind imbalances right when
I see buying and balances like this it's
assigned to me just like this one up
here that I have Supply coming into the
market
so we just hit a low at 07 rallied you
know 17
handles up to 24.
was going sideways I had some bullish
order flow coming in here honestly but
it just went inside inside bar inside
bar inside bar now you're starting to
break down right the three insides
um you know that's a nice pattern you
don't see a lot of them but um inside of
this bar here but anyway then it breaks
out and now I see signs in the order
flow of supply coming into the markets
okay so and at this point you're trading
around you know 15 and then three
quarters 16.
you know I you know it's getting short
at 14 and I think is a safe bet and it
just starts going sideways right you
know I said get short here at 14 if you
could then finally it breaks down but as
it breaks down what do we got we got
actually a bearish prime opponent
control and a bearish slingshot point of
control here the value area is not
tested in the next bar
right we start to sell off rally back up
test this area
and then work our way back down to new
lows
okay but over here what else do you see
right if you've been watching my videos
recently just in this little
time between
you know 1150 and this bar here at 11
56. we'll see a few things right we see
this exhaustion print one here right we
see the thin print in here one and one
seven and six right so you got thin
volumes coming in here
here and here that exhaustion print as
you're coming back in to test the
resistance level is bearish
right so we had some nice bearish
overflow overflow order flow
um but let's get back to I wanted to
just touch really quick on this level
here this is how I I knew that there
wasn't going to be much support in the
market if it could break 4 400 we could
get another you know a strong push down
to me yeah I love round numbers right in
the market they're great reference
points came down here
44 double O it's only 450 there
it's nothing that's like normal volume
in the e-minis wasn't like
a thousand five hundred or two thousands
nothing it's 454. so it got through that
extremely quick now granted it's going
into
um the clothes right it's already 237 at
this time
and what happens right 44 double O just
draw your line here ah I hit F5 instead
of of six uh trying to get all fancy
here but uh just give it a second for
the truck to come back up
but here right let's draw it now F6
right that's your line right 4400 I mean
again it's a level right I I don't use
all necessarily a lot of
levels but you know to me that's a
psychological the whole numbers have
always been psychological levels to me
whether you want to use it or not up to
you but I always watch it how the market
reacts to those levels
and we don't even come back up or get
within you know a tick here a tick here
and we just keep selling off more Supply
coming into the market and just more
negative order flow coming through
all right just by watching the Deltas
you know I remember last week somebody
made a comment Belta doesn't matter
anymore well I don't know I think it
does I I showed you the importance of
that early rally that failed just by
looking at the delta
okay
so anyway guys I hope you guys enjoyed
that video
um I'm still uh you know I'm here in
Chicago and you know a lot of the us is
going through you know some severe
weather
um you know over today it was only about
100 102 or something but uh
you know there's other places down south
and you know I think I've been in triple
digits for a while now
but uh you know
computers my computers I run them all
all day long and it's freaking hot
but uh I am going through your comments
I'm going to put out some videos on them
uh within the next uh you know couple of
days I'm just
uh I got aircon going full blast and all
that but uh it's just uncomfortable
um
right now due to the weather tomorrow
it's going to drop 20 degrees back down
into the 80s so anyway guys I'll catch
you guys on the next video and see you
later bye-bye